how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything mcu and unfortunately we did
not get the spider-man 3 teaser
yesterday on december 25th
christmas day despite rumors from
certified accounts and
film studios and distribution companies
we still didn't get it
and it's upsetting but don't lose hope
just yet
as we can expect the actual teaser to
come within a week and i'll break down
everything we know in this video
so don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all of the latest
spider-man 3 news
and i'll mention the giveaway winner at
the end of this video so again many fans
are disappointed but we do have to think
back to
what the sony executive said the sony
executive said that we would be getting
a spider-man 3
first look by the end of this year now
we only have
six days left within the year which
means we should be getting the teaser
or the so-called first look within the
week now we know that marvel studios
recently came out with an announcement
an official announcement from the
president kevin feige stating that they
were going to give us kind of a sneak
peek of what's to come in 2021 with
marvel studios so it does look like they
do
indeed plan to release some footage
possibly even some teaser trailers for
the eternals for chongqi and they
announced that they're planning to do
this
on december 31st new year's eve so this
could
also be when we could expect to see the
spider-man 3 first look as well
because spider-man 3 is going to be a
2021
mcu film it would make sense that they
show a first look for spider-man 3 on
the same day that they're going to give
teasers and possible first looks for
their other 2021 movies as well
and the timing for everything works out
also spider-man 3 has been filming for
about a month now and
now we're under a year to go until the
official release of spider-man 3 next
december
so it's kind of strange that we don't
even have the title for the movie yet
but that means it should be coming soon
now the only thing that i can think of
that would throw off
sony releasing their first look or this
teaser for spider-man 3 would be some
recent reports by daniel richmond
stating that they don't want to announce
anything until they have officially
signed on toby maguire
based on all of the recent reports he
has committed to the film
but are still working out the final
paperwork now this report came about a
week ago and a lot can happen in a week
and a lot can happen in a few days and
we have six days left
and sony did promise a first look by the
end of the year
so hopefully toby ends up signing on
officially so they can announce the
spider-verse coming in spider-man 3. if
not then perhaps the teaser could just
be the title or maybe they could leave
out scenes where they show the other
spider-man confirming the spider-verse
of course we all want the spider-verse
and it's pretty much 95
confirmed at this point in time but we
want the teaser by the end of the year
so hopefully sony sticks true to what
they said and they actually give us our
first look
this year in december and there's only a
few days left
in december just six to go so hopefully
sony sticks true to their promise
but be sure to subscribe so you stay up
to date on all of the latest spider-man
3 news i'll report it as soon as i hear
it big congratulations to youtube
user triton1 for being the winner of our
modoc funko pop giveaway just email me
in the email my description and i'll get
your prize and for the others i have a
lot
more giveaways coming very soon like the
video if you enjoyed it and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof